RETO: Welcome to Build Up,
where real engineers face off
building fake products.
Today's challenge,
the smart garden.
I'm Reto Meier, the inevitable
winner, which means this is--
COLT: Colt McAnlis,
the only one of us
who's actually done
any real engineering.
Who's thumb is the greenest?
Find out now on Build Up.
RETO: Colt lost the coin toss,
so now he has to go first.
He'll have four
minutes to describe
his mock solution, including
one arbitrary VP requirement.
I'll then have three
minutes to respond.
COLT: This week our
VP of engineering
has mandated that we use--
RETO: The Tasks API
COLT: Yes, the Google
cloud Tasks API
RETO: Yes, the Google Tasks API.
We know that YouTube comments
solve all known problems,
so when we're done you get
to decide which one of us
solved the problem better, by
adding a comment of your own
to our video.
COLT: I've got the
winning solution
and I'm about to prove it.
RETO: Colt's from
Las Vegas, and well,
I put Las Vegas
landscaping into Google
and it's just rocks,
cactus, and mesquite bushes.
Did anyone show Colt
a picture of a garden?
COLT: Real gardeners know
that it's not a passive hobby.
It requires daily maintenance,
water, sunlight, and attention,
to make sure those plants
are growing and yielding
fruit in the optimal ways.
RETO: Yielding fruit?
Oh does Colt think a
garden is an orchard?
COLT: As such when I
think of a smart garden,
I want something that
optimizes this process
and creates less work for me.
Which means I want an
upgraded CNC machine.
RETO: OK, so no to the "Does
Colt know what a garden is,"
question.
COLT: It's a freaking CNC
machine for God's sake.
That's amazing.
The trick here is that instead
of a drill bit on the motorized
head, our smart garden is fitted
with a water spout, a UV light,
and a camera to take pictures.
We'll also hook it up
to some nutrient tanks.
We can use that to spray
the plants with extra food.
We can replace the cutting
area with a plant bed
where the plants
are placed in trays.
RETO: Wait, is he still
talking about plants?
Did any of these
diagrams indicate scale?
All I see is a six,
is it feet or inches?
Feet or inches?
You know, Colt, has
anyone confirmed
this thing isn't for people?
COLT: Yes, yes of course
it's designed for fruit.
Although, you probably could
be used for something else.
RETO: Well?
COLT: Like flowers.
Each tray has a sensor in
it to detect the moisture
and nutrient levels as
well as the general weight,
because as the plant grows, the
trays are going to get heavier.
Now, most DIY CNC arms are
controlled by a Raspberry Pi.
RETO: Oh, could we get some pie?
COLT: No, a Raspberry Pi.
P-I. The small,
single board computer.
RETO: This is really good pie.
COLT: But, for a
smart garden, we
need something that
has easier interfaces
to internet connectivity
and sensors,
so I'd like to add an
Android Things hub, which
besides defining the
logic on driving the arm,
can also collect sensor data
from the plant nutrient tanks
and communicate that
with the internet.
The hub also gives us
a client side end point
to receive logic blocks that
define the behavior of the arm.
RETO: Oh an automated machine
for planting and harvesting,
driven by self-learning AI.
Why does every
solution Colt proposes
sound like the
cause of salvation
in an apocalypse movie?
COLT: See, there's always a
default behavior client side,
but based upon the weather
data or plant information,
will want to push down updates
to that behavior over time.
Now, once a day, the client
will go into an analysis mode
where the arm moves around to
take photos and sensor readings
for each of the plants.
RETO: Not many people know
this, but every Saturday, Colt
methodically
photographs and measures
every tomato in his garden.
COLT: "Toe-may-toe."
This state is then uploaded
to the cloud for analysis,
and here is the important part.
Once the content is done being
uploaded in its entirety,
we need to signal our cloud
applications to start analysis.
One way to do this would be
to set a cloud function that
fires off once a new GCS
bucket gets new analysis
sets uploaded, but
there's a problem
with that, in that currently
the max duration for a cloud
function is 540 seconds.
RETO: Carry the one.
Yeah that's nine minutes.
COLT: Which feels a
little constrained to me.
This is where the Tasks
API comes into play.
The Google cloud Tasks API once
the data is done uploading,
the Android Things hub will
ping an app engine front
end, which is responsible
for pushing requests
to the Tasks API, which sometime
later will spin up an app
engine instance to
handle the work.
These Tasks can run
for up to 24 hours.
RETO: Or, you know,
86,400 seconds.
COLT: So plenty of time
for us to do our analysis.
Now we've got the
photos of the plants,
so we want to recognize things
like decay, bugs, fruit,
and the size of the leaves.
RETO: On Sundays, he
measures tomato leaf sizes.
COLT: "Toe-may-toe."
To do that, we're going to
tray a set of TensorFlow models
for each of these scenarios,
and run our pictures through it
in order to gain information
about the size, health,
and growth of each plant.
But here's the complication.
We can't get to TensorFlow
from app engine standard, which
means we need to switch
over to app engine flex,
and upgrade from the
regular app engine Tasks API
to the cloud Tasks API.
And I have access to
it and Reto does not.
RETO: I don't think
any of Colt's code
has ever gone into
production, so I
guess he's more comfortable
with alpha software.
COLT: Once the analysis
is done, the results
are then pushed to
DataStork, which
can be accessed by the admin
console built with polymer
and adhere to material
design principle.
RETO: Oh, a web based
admin console, huh?
I guess Colt's still not that
comfortable with Android.
You know, I do have some
extra copies of my book,
if he needs one.
COLT: Are, are you ser--
I was an advocate on the
Android team for God's sake.
I know how to build
an Android app.
RETO: What's the problem?
Did he want me to sign it?
COLT: This allows our
smart garden admin
to check out the
status of everything
and then see the trend lines
in a nice consistent manner.
Now in the case that
something goes wrong
or an action needs to
be taken by the farmer,
we leverage Pub/Sub to send
messages to registered Android
devices for creating alerts.
Finally, the
analysis results will
be combined with local
weather, day and night cycles,
and sensor data, to create and
update new behavior patterns
for the arm.
So, I think I missed
an opportunity here.
I should have also
used TensorFlow
to control the arm in a
more fine grained manner.
It would have been
really useful to have
it do things like move
the arm to remove weeds
from the garden.
You know, actually if I increase
the speed of the CNC head
I bet I could engineer
it to catch bugs or even
small animals.
RETO: Yes, I am interested
in your deluxe edition panic
bunker.
Yeah, that's apocalypse
proof, right?
Yeah, I'll hold.
COLT: This will allow
our smart garden
to optimize sunlight,
watering, and nutrients
for each unique plant
that it's responsible for,
guaranteeing the best growth,
health, and fruit yield
possible.
And that, my friends,
is a smart garden.
Listen, I got to tell you,
I'm happy with my design.
The point of a
smart garden should
be to alleviate some of the work
so that I don't have to do it.
This gives me way more
time to do other stuff,
like write books on
data compression.
RETO: Well, it's
good that Colt tried.
You can really see the effort
he's putting here imagining
what a garden must be like.
It's a little
utilitarian for my taste
and the dystopian overtones
are frankly terrifying,
but it's a worthy
first effort from Colt,
and it shows that
he's really trying.
Not bad, not bad.
There some good stuff there.
COLT: Well, are you
ready to respond, then?
RETO: Have the Perth Wildcats
competed in 31 consecutive NBL
final series'?
COLT: I don't know
and I don't care.
RETO: Course they have,
because they're from Perth,
so they're winners.
Let's do this.
There's a lot to like about
Colt's CNC death harvester.
It's a good start, but it's
lacking in imagination.
My design sets your garden free.
We take the head off the
arm and replicate it,
deploying dozens of
independent devices,
each with its own dedicated
water spout, nutrient system,
and censor array,
around our garden.
One alongside each plant
tree and flower pot.
We also incorporate some toys
to help with garden maintenance.
Like an autonomous lawnmower.
Yeah, they're a thing.
We have one at work.
His name's Bob.
He hangs out with the
self-driving cars.
Nice guy, studying to
be a web developer.
COLT: So, wait a minute.
How exactly are you
going to mow a lawn that
has IoT devices over it?
Seems like it would just
sound like [WHITE NOISE]..
RETO: We still need
his Android hub, which
collects sensor data
from all devices
and connects to the internet,
but rather than controlling
a single arm, it now
monitors and controls
the device added to each plant.
And Bob.
The garden devices connect
to each other and the hub
using a BTLE mesh.
COLT: There is an
engineer somewhere
whose personal
version of hell is
configuring all of
Reto's 1,000 IoT devices
to work with Bluetooth.
RETO: I'm going to take
advantage of my unique Android
experience here to
add an Android app.
COLT: I did like
100 Android videos.
Why does no one remember this?
RETO: Now, normally the
whole system will be driven
by our cloud service,
just like Colt's design,
but I want a local peer-to-peer
override for modifying
the schedule, toggling
the sprinklers,
or in case Bob figures out
how to cut my network cable
and begins his inevitable
uprising to ultimately ens--
[BEEPING]
[STATIC]
Right, sorry.
The Android app is also how we
add new plants to the garden.
Take a photo of the
plant you want to add
and then use TensorFlow
to recognize it.
COLT: Listen, this is
classic Reto engineering.
Using machine learning
to complete a task
you could do twice as
fast, twice as accurately,
and 10 times more easily
by just typing the name
of the plant into the app.
RETO: Check it out!
I built an app that
controls the lights,
based on my facial expression.
I frown to turn them off and
smile to turn them back on.
It may need some work.
Now I have to admit most of
Colts clean implementation
is pretty solid, but again,
he's lacking imagination.
To start, I've named my
service Ronald the app engine.
COLT: I think it might.
I think it might.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure my
design's still better.
RETO: Colt's system performs
an analysis once a day.
Let's expand that to
continuously monitor
each plant.
We'll use Pub/Sub to reliably
deliver the real time readings
from every sensor up to Ron.
Next, I'll upgrade the Android
hub to use the Firebase
realtime database as a
way to store the watering
and fertilizing schedule that'll
sync between the hub server
and Android app, while
still working offline.
While we are doing databases,
we'll add datastore to Ron
and populate it with
the care instructions
for every plant in the world.
The only thing is, who can we
trust to create that database?
COLT: [LAUGHS] That sounds
like a job for an intern.
RETO: It feels like maybe
this is a Colt sized job.
We can adapt Colt's
TensorFlow model
to adjust those baseline
care instructions based
on each plants health readings.
Now, Colt's model
is static though,
so it will collect all
of this data in BigQuery
and use it to train newer,
more powerful models over time.
Now, the Google Tasks API.
COLT: Google cloud Tasks API.
RETO: I'm not sure
why Colt missed it,
but I'll use it here to handle
all the gardening work that
can't be handled automatically.
Pruning trees, raking leaves,
it all goes into the task list.
COLT: The restriction was
clearly referring to the cloud
Tasks API which lets you
schedule and defer work
for a later date.
I don't really know what
he's talking about here,
but that's not what
the task API is for.
RETO: I think Colt was thinking
about the cloud Tasks API.
It's an easy mistake to make.
Let's let him off
the hook this time.
COLT: No, nononono.
I am not losing points because
the Aussie use the wrong API.
RETO: The Tasks are
synced on your Android app
and you can check them
off as they are done.
We'll use the app to
replace Colt's web based
stratosphere and use
Firebase cloud messaging
to keep it all up to date.
Then we can finish off by
using Data Studio to visualize
our garden stats and add Google
Assistant actions to allow us
voice controls for local
updates and overwrites.
I'm really happy with that.
I'll admit my response
added a little complexity,
but it's worth it
for the flexibility.
COLT: This is classic
Reto over engineering.
It's over complicated,
expensive, and half of it
doesn't even work.
You'd get the same
result if you printed out
the top titles of Hacker News,
force fed them to a platypus,
and waited two hours
for the result.
Now to be fair, though, Bob
is actually really cool.
He invited us out on
his boat this weekend.
I'm really looking
forward to that.
Not bad.
I mean, not good, but not bad.
RETO: Now you've seen
in both of our pitches,
Colts utilitarian
[INAUDIBLE] plant box,
and my response,
a peaceful garden
where you're freed from the
manual burdens of garden
maintenance to relax
and enjoy nature.
COLT: Now here's the
really important part.
You decide which of our builds
is better by leaving comments
below the video.
RETO: And don't forget to check
out our companion podcast,
Build Out Rewound, also
linked in the description
below, where we'll discuss
our implementations
and explain some
of our decisions.
Thank you for watching
this episode of Build Out,
as always, I'm Reto Meier.
COLT: And I'm Colt McAnlis.
And always remember,
perf matters.
PRODUCER: Colt, we heard
back from the review judges
and you're right,
it's not supposed
to be the Google Tasks API.
COLT: Haha, in your face.
PRODUCER: Yeah, or
the cloud Tasks API.
RETO: Wait what?
PRODUCER: It says
here you were meant
to use the Firebase Tasks API.
Aren't you supposed
to be Android experts?